At this point, we've built
an application that got the latitude and
longitude of your device.
Well done.
Did you notice a difference between
this app and the one we created earlier?
This app just updated the lat-long once,
and then it left it at those values,
whereas the previous one
updated the data periodically.
Now what did we do
differently this time?
Take a look at the code and see.
There's an important and distinct
difference between the two samples and
learning what that is will help
you build better location apps.
If you need a hint, take a look
in the unconnected override and
you'll see the difference
between the two apps.